yeah we represent Senate by been Santa
Barbara how long you been down here zero
seven years seven years and what is your
burger to us heroin hero
what age did you first eat in droves
I've started pie like when I was 13 with
weed and then and then coke PCP and
there just escalated when I turned 20 I
started I try heroin once I didn't like
it
believe it or not and I left set up I
moved back to LA to the stay with my mom
for three years and I went back to Santa
Barbara and all my friends were using so
I just been I've been my whole life and
it's just terrible
it's a big night your overdose oh god
yeah anytime
what's that like I think you don't know
cause y'all remember none of it there's
so times I've got up off the ground and
looking for my [ __ ] in there I like this
shot you know you just so deed you don't
really remember it years out it's gone
yeah yeah
you're clean yeah yeah I'm mad at a
sober living home in Santa Barbara
called Wooldridge I looked at the
airport I had two full-time jobs and I
relapse I got off parole and I want to
move up north to be with a friend of
mine and I gave to extort us I moved up
there and relapsed up north and this is
part of that still I went from there to
San Diego to a program to try to quit
and I didn't didn't work and I was on my
way back to Santa Barbara a 40-minute
layover here in LA and I never got back
on the bus that's how I got stuck down
here on the street our tent on there
they're trying to give me housing
sometimes I'm hard to reach because I
still my phones left and right you can't
just enjoy you can't keep nothing you
know so I'm we're back on that again so
I just got in contact with everybody in
there they're all jion's today you
missed like six referrals to go
somewhere so hopefully a Tuesday I have
an appointment and also what happens
[Music]
and then there's anybody shopping you
had whatever clearance I had both
parents until I was ten and my dad was
an alcoholic they divorced she remarried
I'm that's how I ended up in LA my dad
continued on and he went and finally got
clean and sober he went to AAA and so he
was nineteen years clean sober when you
die so I know a like tobacco man I know
I'm pulling the wool over my eyes you
know I can't pull myself because I still
go through the motions yeah
yeah I have three I didn't write them I
was incapable of don't knock the drugs
just had me my aunt raised my two
youngest girls and my my oh man my
boyfriend's father raised my son you
know how do you ever find everything my
sons in prison um my daughter sir
they're just thinking how they're sick
of it
cuz I'm on and off on and off but there
was a time I was clean for like three
years my grandpa that was died of cancer
and he asked me if I could to help him
take care of him here so I cleaned up by
Method on and took care of him and
during that period of time I saw my
girls and on a regular basis and and I
was molested by my grandfather and so I
always talk to my kids about that and
they told me I know what I don't know
when it started but I think it started
off for young and ended when I was about
nine and I saw used to always talk to my
girls about that and I went to visit him
one time in my oldest daughter funny
told me that her uncle was touching them
and so um I didn't know what to do I
called police and rest occation whatever
and so now I'm the bad guy and my uncle
got eight months work furlough so he
really didn't do no jail time and then I
can't nobody talks to me anymore because
I called the cops
I don't know where else do ya what would
you say to your kids right now
I would just want them to know that I
didn't purposely choose drugs over them
you know I can't explain it but it's
just an overwhelming obsession to use
and the ones that I got started like
stop I didn't know any better it's
really hard can't explain unless you go
through it you know it just [ __ ] up my
whole life you know I come here family
businesses and all that and I wasn't a
part of it because I was whatever I can
I recycle I'm selling prostitution
whatever I can do oh yeah yeah a lot a
lot mostly up in the state of Washington
I don't know why up there but know that
there was really bad you pull knives
guns are just somehow managed to get
away every time I just knew how to act a
certain way and distract him just to pop
the door and get out of the car you know
what Cynthia thank you for for sure
you're tired yeah okay